is
kylie jenner's daughter stormy webster
is growing up fast and already
impersonating her famous moms i can't
while the 24 year old reality star was
trying to promote her new swim line on
her insta stories thursday
you want to tell my swim launches
tomorrow
her three-year-old daughter couldn't
help but pop in and make an adorable
little cameo i am so excited
that kylie swim
is finally launching tomorrow at 3 p.m
no but seriously the way stormy
literally just pops into the frame i am
so excited
that kylie swim
is finally launching tomorrow at 3 p.m
okay carry on i'm getting so many
compliments
yes i've been getting so many
compliments on the fit
and just everything about it and i just
can't wait for you guys to get your
hands on it and try it's me hi everybody
kylie jenner what
stormy already has that influencer intro
down i'm playing jenner and this seems
to be a trend with the newest generation
of kardashian jenner kids having kids is
just there's no way to describe it but
it's a lot earlier this month kim
kardashian's eldest daughter
eight-year-old northwest totally called
out her mom for using a different voice
when she posts on social media what do
you talk differently why do i talk
different for what when i do videos for
my videos i'm the same human being i
don't talk different
how do i talk different
guys do you think i talk different when
i'm talking about contour yeah
you do too penelope how do i talk guys
guys
i got this
is that we is that what i say is that
what i sound like
but back to kylie i love it fans noticed
that the kylie cosmetics founder who's
expecting baby number two with her
boyfriend travis scott was wearing a
gold chain necklace with the years 2018
and 2022 on it seemingly symbolizing the
year stormy was born and the year her
new baby will arrive earlier this month
the beauty mogul confirms she's pregnant
with her second child in a sweet
instagram video are you ready to go to
mommy's doctor yeah
and a source recently told et that it's
important to kylie and travis that they
prepare stormy for her future baby
sibling quote they are making sure she
knows how loved she is and preparing her
to be a big sister by keeping her very
engaged kylie can't wait to be a new mom
again she feels like she was born to be
a mom and can't wait to start another
chapter of her life with stormy and
travis by her side